Hey everyone, we are here and we are going to be looking at some adverse selection work problems.
Now what I'm going to do is walk you through a series of questions and talk about why answers are the correct ones, why they're not the correct ones, and just explaining some adverse selection in general.
Now the key thing to keep in mind with adverse selection, one of the key things is that adverse selection is typically pre contractual.
That is, there's information that's hidden from one party prior to the contract being completed.
So with that in mind, let's go ahead and jump into our questions.
Question number one.
Which scenario best exemplifies adverse selection in health insurance?
A company finds that mostly older sicker individuals apply for health insurance.
This kind of could be adverse selection if the company didn't know.
But since they find out that this is going to be the case, then we can say it's not quite adverse selection.
If the, if the individuals, the older secret individuals were hiding that information, that would be an appropriate response.
Health insurance premiums rising as healthier individuals opt out of buying insurance.
Yeah, this is going to be our answer.
And the reason why is we have these healthier individuals who know this about themselves.  Okay?
They know they're healthier.
They don't feel like they need insurance because they, they know that they're healthier.
The insurance companies might not know about this, but what they do see, the, the insurance companies do see is that they have less people inside of their insurance pool which is going to cause those insurance premiums to rise for everyone.
Thus created a problem for the insurance company because now they're going to have people who aren't happy about the higher premiums.
So this is why we're going to have adverse selection in the health insurance market.
There the other two health insurance companies providing wellness programs, that's just a way to get people to get them better educated and things like that to mitigate any type of risk that they may have a new health policy that mandates every individual to have insurance coverage that really doesn't pertain to adverse selection.
Which situation reflects adverse selection in the hiring process?  All right.
A company uses a standardized test to evaluate all job applicants.
That is a screen.
All right, That's a screen.
So that's not what we're really looking for.
A company provides.
A company provides on the job training to new hires.
No, that's not going to be adverse selection in the hiring process.
You already hired the person.
A firm finds that job postings for high stress positions attract fewer highly qualified candidates.
Yeah, that's going to be the answer here.
Where's my pin?
There we go.
That's going to be our answer there.
And this is just because what we're seeing is the fewer, higher quality candidates, we don't know who, who is actually going to be the highly qualified candidates.
What we get is 100 people who want to have that position.
There might be five people who are actually highly qualified for it.
And so we have this adverse selection that arises because now the company's having to spend resources to actually go through this whole process.
And the last one, that's not going to be related to adverse selection.
Which example is indicative of adverse selection in the loan market?  Okay.
A bank offers a low interest rate to customers with high credit scores.
No, that's going to be a signal and kind of a screen at the same time to those high credit score consumers.
A payday loan company notices a high default rate amongst or among its borrowers.
Yeah, that's our answer.
And the reason why this is going to be our answer is because these high default rate people, they are going to the payday loan company knowing that they're going to be defaulting anyway.
So there's some information that they have to this entire situation that payday loan company doesn't have.
So that puts that company at risk of having all those default rate people and so they could potentially lose a lot of its money.
So the other one, this is just going to be a screen here and automated system for faster alone approval.
They could also do a screen with that one.
So what we are really looking for is going to be B, which action is a form of screening to mitigate adverse selection in life insurance.
So we're looking for a screen.
In this case we are looking for a screen requiring a medical exam before approving a life insurance policy.
We need go no further.
This is the answer.
That is a screen.
That's a perfect example of what a screen is.
Increasing premiums for all policyholders.  No.
Offering a discount for younger applicants.  No.
Providing online health assessments.
That last one potentially.
But here you're requiring that medical exam before you actually get the life insurance.
Life insurance companies actually do this at certain amounts.
So yeah, they're screening that person to make sure that they're not going to be at risk in terms of losing out on all the insurance that they would have to pay out.
So they don't want to pay out a ton of insurance because the candidate was in poor health to begin with.
So that's what they're checking in on there.
Alright, number whatever this is what is an effective screening method to reduce adverse selection in hiring.
All right, Offering higher salaries to attract more applicants, that's more of a signal.
Implementing employee referral programs.
We've already seen that.
Conducting detailed interviews and skill assessments.
Yeah, that's our answer.  That's a screen here.
You're trying to find out more information about that party that is potentially going to be your employee.
So that is going to be what we are looking for there.
Our next one, how can higher educational credentials serve as a signaling mechanism in the job market?
So you, you are taking a MBA course now.
You are trying to and hopefully will get your mba.
And so what are you trying to do?
You're trying to signal the fact that, that you're a high quality candidate.
And so what we need to do is look for something like that.  So let's go through these.
Expand the training programs available to employees, job seekers pursuing advanced degrees to boost their employment prospects.
Hey, that's just what we were talking about.
So that is going to be our answer because you are letting the people know I went and got an advanced degree, which means that I have more technical skills and I'm a better quality employee.  So please hire me.  Right.
So that's going to be our answer there.
Okay, next question.
Why does risk aversion lead to adverse selection in the, in health insurance markets?
So let's go through our answers here.
Risk averse individuals are more likely to buy comprehensive health insurance.
Yeah, what you're doing here is you are going to be putting more of the risk to the health insurance company by trying to just get rid of all the risk that you have.
That's why we get the insurance to get rid of the risk that we have and put it on somebody else.
So if you buy that comprehensive health insurance, you're buying a much bigger package there and that is going to put more risk on health insurance companies.
Thus that is how we tie those two together here.
Companies offering a variety of insurance products.  Products.  No.
Health insurance plans being sold without a medical examination.
Let's see about that one.
No, because we're not really talking about risk aversion in enough detail here.
There may be some background risk aversion that's taking place.
We don't know that.
The issue is we don't know who is going to be going without the medical.
Going with the insurance without a medical examination.
With the first one, we have a better direct link as to what we see with risk aversion and adverse selection.
All right, and our last one, which scenario best illustrates the interaction of risk aversion and adverse selection in an insurance market.
So let's go with these again.
A insurance companies offer lower premiums for individuals with a safe driving record.
That's a pricing strategy that the insurance company is going after there.
It is targeting people who are going to be more low risk in terms of their driving habits.
But it's not really direct relationship between risk aversion, adverse selection, or it's not as direct enough, I don't think.  So.
Let's look at the other ones.
Consumers with a high risk of health issues are more likely to purchase comprehensive health insurance.
So this is kind of like the last one that we had, I believe, where we have people who are trying to, let's say, basically pass off all of the risks that they would have to the insurance company.
So what we are seeing here is they are definitely trying to get rid of the risk that they have and put it onto someone else.
And so that is likely going to be the best one, I believe.
Let's look for the other ones here.
A life insurance company introduces bonuses for policyholders who do not file any claims.
This is more or less just a reward mechanism as opposed to showing us the link between risk aversion and adverse selection.
And then lastly, car insurance rates are adjusted based on the safety features installed in a vehicle.
This one's like a.
In that what you're doing is you're rewarding or you're discounting the insurance that somebody's going to pay.
It kind of relates to the, to the interaction between those two items.
Risk aversion, adverse selection.
But it's not as strong as what we see with B.
So it's not as strong as what we see with B here.
This is going to be definitely transferring risk from one person to another person as opposed to just giving discounts or doing some other type of pricing strategy.
So that's why we were choosing B as our answer and that is all of our questions.
I hope you have enjoyed it and we will catch you in our last one.